cela est une tragédie et bien ce sont
les mots de poutine on n'avait pas le
choix rajoute t-il il estime que
l'offensive russe se poursuit calmement
il espère aussi que le bon sens
prévaudra à l'ouest gauthier rybinski
les mots utilisés vont faire sursauter
les des occidentaux oui parce qu'il ya
toujours la même interrogation est ce
que vladimir poutine croit elle lui-même
a ce don qu'il fantasme est ce qu'ils
croient vraiment sa propre propagande
c'est toujours la complexité du
personnage parce que lorsqu ils
l'estiment dans le mieux à même foulée
dans le même ordre d'idées que la
nazification de l'ukraine exigeait une
opération de ce type là encore
comment peut-il dire cela alors
évidemment vous avez entendu ce que
disait sylvain rousseau disant que le
bataillon azoff donc composé de
néo-nazis craignent un et qui essaye
justement de faire croire ou de
d'accréditer l'idée que la russie est en
train d'utiliser des armes chimiques ils
sont à l'oeuvre oui mais le reste du
pouvoir ukrainien alors s'est il est
utile de que nous soulignons
effectivement il faut que l'ukraine soit
l'air sur un certain nombre de choses et
notamment celle là mais dans l'esprit de
vladimir poutine
lorsqu'il dit que l'intervention est
justifiée à cause d'un régime nazi c'est
évidemment faux lorsqu'il dit que il est
en train de libérer l'ukraine
c'est évidemment faux sinon il n'y
aurait pas autant de soldats russes
morts et lorsqu'il dit qu'il espère que
le l'ouest sera calme où sera
raisonnable là il a malheureusement
peut-être raison on voit les images
derrière vous de poutine avec son allié
biélorusse alexandre loukachenko
ils ont quitté moscou pour aller à
l'extrême est à
vostochny c'est là
pour commémorer le vol de youri gagarine
dans l'espace t soit il ya 61 ans
loukachenko la la girouette de poutine
alors moins qu'auparavant parce que
loukachenko à travers la crise ennuis la
guerre en ukraine est devenu presque non
seulement un allié pour poutine mais
c'est pour lui c'est pour la survie
lukashenko qu'il a besoin de vladimir
poutine rendez vous compte qu'il ya au
début même de la guerre à l'occassion qu
avait dit il n'y aura pas de troupes
biélorusse est la seule chose qu'il soit
parvenu à garantir parce que pour le
reste il a permis l'invasion de
l'ukraine puisque les troupes sont venus
de biélorussie et qu'il se rend bien
compte surtout lukashenko c'est que même
s'il essaie de donner des garanties à
l'ouest personne ne le croit parce il a
détourné une élection parce que son pays
est une russie puis puissance 10 sur le
le thème est dans le domaine des
libertés mais parce qu'il sait aussi que
non seulement une intelligentsia
biélorusse ne le suis plus et depuis
fort longtemps mais qu'il y à des remous
dans l'armée biélorusse et qu'il y a
apparemment fort peu de gens m'aiment
pas remis au sein de l'état-major
biélorusse qui seraient prêts à se
lancer dans une aventure en soutien aux
troupes russes pour justement continuer
et perpétuer la guerre en ukraine est
donc là il les pieds poings liés à
vladimir poutine et celui ci le sait il
en profite parce que de temps en temps
on a vu que loukachenko pouvait être
turbulent comme allié vis-à-vis de
poutine mais klein n'a pas le choix
qu'il est
vraiment l'obligé du maître du kremlin
et que d'une certaine manière ça peut
remettre aussi c'est toujours la même
histoire ça peut remettre les ukrainiens
en alerte lorsqu'on sait que la
biélorussie et dans l'étude you si vous
me passez l'expression ça veut dire que
ceux ci la biélorussie à nouveau abrite
des mouvements de troupes russes eh bien
ça veut dire que le front de kiev kiev
qui est juste en dessous de la frontière
entre l'ukraine et la russie sadek le
front de kiev peut se rouvrir et c'est
peut-être ça l'information qui est
adressé à la fois par coutinho
lukashenko aux ukrainiens c'est une
grande inquiétude en ukraine